>> My name is David Kuria from Nairobi, Kenya,
a social entrepreneur for [INAUDIBLE].
On public environmental issues and I think
really the -- the failure to
reach a consensus from the Copenhagen conference
last year, [INAUDIBLE]
our globe and our economic development.
In particular for Africa where the mitigations
and the challenges of
mitigations in Copenhagen with the impacts
of climate change are
intermost.
And we have seen this things happening especially
the extended droughts
and really coping up with the expected downfalls
which are really to
Africans citizens unmanageable.
And we have seen really lots of deaths emanating
from the poverty of
the effects of climate change, loss of income
and poor people and I
think it's the [INAUDIBLE] governments global
leader which we think on
the future of the climate change.